sí
[Música]
hablamos de salud en directo américa ya
está conmigo en el estudio más romeros
alaya como es costumbre mar feliz inicio
de semana feliz lunes para ti muy buen
día vamos a hablar como lo adelantábamos
en el sumario de los efectos del comit
19 - estudiado uno de ellos la
consecuencia de la enfermedad de
nuestras funciones cognitivas y también
cerebrales que grave no si de hecho él
tiene un nombre ya en inglés le han
puesto brain folk que se traduciría como
niebla mental o nivel cerebral que no es
un término médico pero nos sirve para
agrupar una serie de dolencias que han
sentido pacientes después de recuperarse
del comité en sí que es como por ejemplo
problemas de atención en la memoria
falta de rapidez cerebral incluso
problemas con el habla para hablar de
todo esto como cada lunes estamos con el
doctor carlos eduardo pérez médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia muy buenos días doctor
cuéntenos sabemos porque el contagio de
kobe termina afectando nuestras
funciones cognitivas
veamos que la enfermedad por code mal es
una enfermedad sistémica se enferma que
compromete todos los órganos y en esa
actividad inflamatoria que hay del
pulmón del corazón también se inflama el
cerebro y al inflamarse el cerebro eso
produce esos trastornos que se han visto
como ese déficit cognitivo que pueden
ser leves de algunas pérdidas
transitorias de memoria o severas con
pérdida y ausencia de memoria y
recuerdos cercanos es un gran problema y
estamos estudiando porque se trata de
cómo tratar esta patología hola doctor
carlos cómo está feliz de un feliz
inicio de semana le preguntó entonces si
hay más posibilidad de desarrollar está
a nivel mental si se sufre de kobe grave
si raúl es entre más severa sea la
enfermedad
más probabilidad que haya un daño y que
ese año sea más extenso sin embargo en
personas que tienen síntomas mínimos
también se ha relacionado estas
alteraciones cognitivas esta es una
enfermedad dinámica es una enfermedad
que lleva en la humanidad un año y medio
dos años y hasta ahora estamos
aprendiendo sus consecuencias a mediano
plazo pero no las conocemos a largo
plazo y tal vez una de las más complejas
es esta de la alteración cognitiva de la
alteración del conocimiento en el
mediano plazo de la enfermedad el doctor
cuéntenos esto ocurre con alguna otra
enfermedad porque quizás eso podría
ayudar a estudiar o saber qué efectos
puede tener no sólo con el kobe se ve la
relación entre problemas cognitivos y
una enfermedad infecciosa por ejemplo
no se conocen varias enfermedades y
sobre todo en pacientes que han estado
en unidades de quan tens y vo hay unos
síndromes de estos pacientes
críticamente enfermos que requieren
sedación ventilación mecánica altas y
muchos días de estancia en unidades
críticas que salen con este tipo de
alteraciones y enfermedades como un
negro infecciones que también producen
estos trastornos de la funcionalidad
cognitiva nos conocemos sin embargo en
kobe es decir estamos aprendiendo cuál
es la magnitud pero esta es una
enfermedad que digamos es usual en
infecciones muy severa doctor le
pregunté entonces si existen ya
tratamientos para solucionar estos
problemas cognitivos
es estos tratamientos se basan en la
rehabilitación recuerde mos que el
cerebro de una plasticidad de una
capacidad de modificarse adaptarse muy
grande entonces con terapias como por
ejemplo rehabilitación visual
rehabilitación
auditiva
rehabilitación de la memoria ejercicios
se hace un proceso guiado para recuperar
algunas de las funciones esto no se hace
completamente no hay medicamentos para
esto se hace a través del proceso de
rehabilitación y acompañamiento y
digamos que están las alternativas que
se están ofreciendo hoy actualmente los
pacientes este que hablamos es uno de
los efectos de kobe largo que estamos
viendo no también hay temas de salud
mental por ejemplo también hay problemas
físicos fatigas problemas de respiración
se están estudiando suficiente la la
magnitud que puede tener que gran parte
de la población que ha sufrido kobe y
luego siga teniendo síntomas meses
después
y esto que se llama el lonko y con el
prolongado es lo que está es el gran
desafío que estamos en la post pandemia
ya hay unidades en américa latina en
colombia y unidades de posco y en el
mundo se están abriendo en donde están
buscando todos estos pacientes se cree
que más o menos sería 30 40 por ciento
de las personas que han tenido un qubit
grave pueden tener alguna complicación a
largo término del código leve o grande
pero alguna complicación por eso
necesitamos entender más aprender más y
especializarnos en lo que se llamó hoy
prolongado lonko y secuelas de kobe para
poder establecer pautas de tratamiento
en un futuro estaremos muy pendientes de
todo lo que sucede con estas
investigaciones porque claramente va a
ser uno de los desafíos más grandes que
tendremos ya futuro de la pandemia más
allá de la vacunación más allá de todos
los problemas de los contagios en sí
entonces bueno pues veremos cómo se
desarrolla nuestra sociedad también con
estos problemas a largo plazo así es
mari doctor muchísimas gracias por
hablar no de toda esta salud que tiene
que ver con la pandemia de cohetes sino
de que al final no se terminan
conociendo real y cuáles son las
implicaciones que tiene esta pandemia en
nuestra en nuestra salud en general
vamos ahora con nuestro segundo invitado
el día